[Music]
well the last presidential debate was
two days ago and one of our writers is
still steamed up about it not happy here
to discuss why is mr. Deon Cole
thanks Conan I wrote this piece about
Mitt Romney's performance Monday night
but I thought I would be pretty
stereotypical to come out here and be
the angry black guys slamming Romney so
I decided to get another writer to do
the bit that I wrote here's another one
all right as mr. Brian Kiley
thanks Conan Mitt Romney you sneaky
white ass cracker agreeing with
everything my man Obama said to keep you
from getting your ass whooped us black
people recognized what you were doing
trying to act all presidential and word
please
when it comes to keeping America safe
Obama's the man because of his foreign
policies I was able to sit safely in my
living room and watch these debates with
some of the hottest [ __ ] this side of
San Bernardino I mean these women are
fine we're talking about racks on racks
on racks and serious junk in the trunk
and MIT quit dissing china-us black
people love the way China do business
where else can you get ten movies on one
DVD for five dollars me being a thick
dark chocolate cinnamon mocha
frappuccino brother I can tell you you
will never understand the black
experience have you ever gotten a dwb
mitt driving while black
well they pull my black ass over all the
time and those mother ain't playing
[Music]
but it's cool I'm just going to keep
marching them trenches keeping it real
and letting the haters hate peace out
y'all
[Applause]